[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm linked this week at the brown table
of dim lighting we're discussing what's
it like after you put out a series like
The Lost years series what what has our
experience been like since sharing
everything we've shared and now fielding
a lot of responses and including a lot
of questions because that's what we
asked you guys to do is tell us use
hashtag your business let us know how
you're processing it and and if you have
any questions for us
and so we knew we were going to do what
we were calling a follow-up episode and
this is it at least this is one of them
oh yeah I would say this is one of them
let's just say it's one and we may get
to some questions but I think one of the
conversations we've been having is as
we've processed how we're how we're
processing
the reaction it kind of just led to the
decision to take today's episode in a
slightly different direction but I'm not
saying it won't end up in a place of
answering questions but we'll talk about
that one quick thing we do want to cover
is if you're listening to this you might
know that the podcast comes out every
Monday in audio form but through the
power of video we are also recording
every single episode with a video camera
have been for quite some time
and then the following Sunday so a
little bit less than a week after the
podcast comes out the video version
comes out at youtube.com slash Urbis so
if you want to see us talk and not just
hear us talk if you if you're like
listening you're like man they're
referring to a photo or man I don't know
exactly how to take what he's saying
maybe the look on his face would help me
understand it oh he was actually smiling
when he said that right oh yeah he was
crying at that point well and so if you
want to see us smile and cry then go to
the ear biscuits channel on YouTube
and also made reference to my hair
during my episode where I told my story
and then but you're done with that
regretfully I watched a little bit of
that and it was like well it was an
interesting decision I'm not saying I'm
not gonna do it again but but we're not
gonna talk about it now because it's not
I'm not even gonna tell you what my hair
looks like today because you'll have to
watch it on YouTube to figure that out
here well that's at least at least 0.4%
of the listening audience is here for my
hair but that means that 99.6% are here
for other things like my hair my hat and
my jacket
you want to get a load of my head I'll
get link has on a hat and a jacket so do
you can you can almost see it how do you
want to how do you want to get into this
because that I do think it's you know
the the brief conversation we had last
night
I called you in a panic you called me in
a panic no you didn't call me in a panic
but you're like hey we you know we
should talk about how we're gonna
approach this thing because I think I
think this is yeah yeah good a place to
start because we were each individually
pulling questions and comments that we
wanted to address or respond to at least
that was our plan yeah well and it turns
out independently we were we were having
our own our own struggles with how how
we wanted to have this discussion today
right so when I called you last night I
had just gotten out of therapy he's
busting out the barn doors and I you
know I don't know if you're experienced
those of you who go to therapy for I
mean for me I always go in thinking why
am I doing this like you know I got
nothing to say I got nothing to talk
about what am I gonna do just makes it
like I all I always lo myself back into
this place where I kind of just feel
like it's unnecessary and
by the end of I'm like this is why I go
to therapy
well this as a side note this brings up
something very pertinent that I'm I'm
not going to talk about right now but I
will talk about later in this episode
continue oh well that was a tease and I
the so the first thing I started talking
about was you know Jesse and I had had
like basically a fight about you know we
read of course we're redoing the pool
area and so this is you know typical
cliche marry couple construction project
arguments situation and but I kind of
had this sense that there was something
going on beneath my concern about the
construction project that was fueling
the intensity with which I was arguing
about this and all standing up for
things like you know where grills will
be and or where grill will be I don't
I'm not like you I'm only gonna have one
grill
I'm not going to grill already losing
but it's what it's a it's a nice grill
like way it might be one grill better
than both of your girls put together
well that's at least when I'm going you
were waving the white flag at the design
phase and I'm all for it so I am I was
like you know I I'm been feeling like
kind of tired and sort of worn out and
it isn't like we're not working hard
well we're not working as hard as it can
get for us like they're yeah we're not
worrying we don't have a major project
besides our own going things that we're
doing but I'm like it's just usually I
would be like have a lot of energy but
I'm like I just feel a little bit beat
down and I started trying to process
that and that was when I started
realizing that this the process of the
are stories going out there and then
them sort of people interacting with
them interacting with the stories
interacting with us it's been a very
emotionally draining thing no I don't I
want to clarify that
you know it's also been awesome just
because it's been emotionally draining
doesn't mean that it hasn't been great I
mean the amount of encouragement that
we've received from people on both ends
of the spectrum aid regardless of
whether or not they you know people who
started not being a Christian and became
a Christian people who were Christian or
non-christian people are still a
Christian it no matter what your point
of reference is for the story we've
received so much encouragement and just
kind messages and thoughtful comments
mm-hmm and that's been great hearing
people's stories but for me the thing
that I realized I was kind of focusing
on this is not too surprising was the
small the small percentage of people who
I kind of felt disapproved by I SEP
disapproved of okay bye-bye them and you
know to kind of I don't worry I'm not
gonna talking critical response yeah
well people who I mean there's there
some responses that are just not
critical and not thoughtful and those
are those are really easy to just be
like okay I'm not gonna let that affect
me but there are some that are critical
and thoughtful and the way my
personality interacts with that is I
just have this like I get immediately
defensive right and so what I want to do
is I want to come on the show and I want
to go through the questions and the
critiques and I want to enter into some
sort of like defense of my position I
want to justify the conclusions that
I've come to right but maybe beyond that
it wasn't there was also people who kind
of did like a takedown essentially of
like my story or whatever and my story
was kind of easier to do a takedown of
because I kind of presented like these
this very specific process that I went
through from an intellectual standpoint
so people
kind of key in on things be like well
here's the thing I took issue with here
and here's the thing I take issue with
here and then there were people
interacting with the people who had
those kind of critical responses who
didn't know who I was didn't know who
you were didn't listen to the podcast
but immediately we're interpreting me
through the lens of this person who's
being critical and and and I felt and I
met this isn't one person this there's a
there's a number of people have done
this and I felt super defensive because
I felt like I was being misrepresented
right and so I just realized that and I
didn't even understand that I was
dealing with this until I started
talking it out mm-hmm and just this idea
of wanting to be like well this is what
you I didn't say that or you just said
this about me or you assumed this about
my process or you're being critical of
me and the way that I thought about this
or the resource that I suggested and I
have all these answers that I want to
get into mm-hmm but then I very quickly
just started realizing that I just don't
want this podcast to devolve into like a
defense of the position that we have you
know the conclusions that we have come
to for a number of reasons number one
I'm most curious about what the if
you're gonna number them what the what
are your personal reasons because I know
I yeah I agree that one of the reasons
is that it's not that's not what that's
not what this podcast did yeah right
well I was just say yes this is no it's
not what the podcast is it's like this
isn't some defense of any you know this
isn't a this isn't a place to come on
and defend and conjecture because that's
not what everybody's here for but also
that when we're not qualified to do that
you know I'm I am not an expert in any
of the stuff that I talked about I'm
just an interested layperson who was who
had their faith basically turned over by
just looking in
to some of these things but I'm not then
qualified to then tell you what you
should think about it I'm out because
when I start thinking about my process
like it wasn't it wasn't easy to revisit
a lot of those things because sometimes
you're like well in the past I was very
interested in this particular thing and
I looked it up and I was convinced of
something but if you ask me why were you
convinced
I can't immediately recall why I was
convinced a lot of times you'll become
convinced of something yeah but the
specific reasons you were convinced I
gotta kind of read that resource again
to get back to that place because that's
just the way the human mind works right
doesn't mean that I didn't come to a
conclusion and didn't move to something
else but anyway the idea of getting into
this like tit-for-tat
defending a position it just felt like
he would be very unhealthy for me
personally but it also felt like I was
just very quickly just kind of moving
into this place that it was about me and
it was about my ego which is a which is
a consistent problem for me right I mean
I talked a little bit about being a 3 on
the inning Graham and one of the
weaknesses of the three and being an
achiever and a performer is you want
everyone everyone's approval mm-hmm and
so the idea of throwing something out
there throwing a bomb out there like we
did and being like this sacred thing
that is the most important thing in so
many people's lives and was the most
important thing in our life we've
discarded it for the most part that is
going to that's throwing a rock into a
hornet's nest in the hole and some of
the Hornets will come out and sting you
yeah and I just realized that I'm just
not I wasn't D I'm not haven't been
dealing with that in a healthy way
because my response to that has been
well let me tell you why I'm justified
let me prove to you why I was right
about this this thing and it's like no
hey that wouldn't be effective it's not
like that's gonna change anybody's mind
mm-hmm but B that wouldn't be good for
me
yeah and I think that as we've talked
about on this podcast and like I'd like
I just said this is not that's not how
we've built this thing this podcast you
know I was really glad when you called
it to hear you say that because I didn't
know I didn't know why when I was
looking back at the questions that I was
I was kind of stuck or kind of troubled
by it but that that helped make sense of
it that yeah this this podcast is a
conversation between us sharing our
experiences and our perspectives on
things with each other and I think if
how whatever how whatever people want to
take from that as a listener is they're
free to do that but if we start turning
towards the microphones and the cameras
and we start saying you know in it a
little bit of that made sense it's like
hey these are the resources if you're
interested in some of the things that
either one of us talked about you know
these are the books you can read if
you're interested in that if you're into
it but you're not gonna sit here and go
through all of these arguments about
okay now let's do a podcast dedicated to
Jesus and all all all of the takeaways
from our research about that and the
conversations we've had and let's start
doing something that's like that's
challenging or that has an agenda or or
puts out a specific perspective that
then we're hoping to change people's
minds I think it's more of I mean even
when we would in previous episode when
we would just give relational advice or
life advice and half the time it would
just be for the fun of it yeah we would
often say listen we're not experts at
this we're just sharing our lives and
our perspectives take it take it with
caution and sometimes with grain of salt
I mean we're just people you know that's
not we're people
we're friends having a conversation that
we're we welcome you to be a part of it
but we don't want to be prescriptive and
we don't want to start arguing on a
soapbox about anything so yeah it
started to feel like it was the
temptation was there to be very
defensive with some of the questions and
yeah because of the nature of your story
it generated a lot more of those
questions that weren't personal in
nature but they were intellectual in
nature or they were philosophical or
just belief oriented they were they were
separate from you as a person
and it does invite those kind of
conversations and I think having started
to address those now would just
perpetuate that and that's not what
that's not where after yeah for me I
think that I felt a lot more I mean you
you felt you talked about how you felt
relief and how there was a lot of
positive ripple effects from this
podcast too and you you know you could
talk more about that but I would say I
mean that's predominantly what I what
I've experienced definitely the relief
of getting it out there and I knew it
but I didn't fully appreciate how
sharing so much of our conversations at
this desk at this table but not sharing
that had kind of really eaten away at me
it really made me uncomfortable to seem
like I was being real but then I wasn't
being it wasn't like a full disclosure
so i i i think i have experienced some
lightness associated with getting that
out there you know and like you said i I
definitely did as well it wasn't until I
started thinking about the this
follow-up which we were like that's
because questions make comments and
respond to them and then I just started
finding myself kind of keying in on
the critical ones or the quite the the
gotcha questions people asking a
question because they think that by me
and trying to answer it they're gonna
they're gonna get me and they're gonna
catch me in some illogical thought
process you know right whereas whereas
with my story it was so you know it was
told in a way that like if if if people
were critical of me they would have been
critical it would it could have been
taken as a personal attack of a personal
experience not just some external
assessment of of a belief about
something well and that's a and I think
that that's a thing that is that's
difficult for me is that even though I
kind of told a story which was like
these are the things that I read or
learned that then made me question what
I had always known some people
interacted with the points right some
people might be like I think your
conclusion here was incorrect or I think
you know I think you've given too much
credence to these critical thinkers you
know people who are critical of the
Bible versus people who believe it
whatever but the majority of people find
some sort of fault with with me right
well you you know it was something in
your process something in your pride
something in the way that you see things
you ultimately want it out you just
didn't know it like trying to find some
way to explain it based on some
deficiency in me right now first of all
you may be right about that but that's
kind of beside the point what I'm
talking about right now is it's
difficult to not take it personally even
though it's it's difficult for people to
not make it personal and I'm not saying
oh it was you and it was your personal
process I think yeah things that you
said can be separated from you but for
you they weren't yeah well I want to be
clear I'm not I'm not complaining about
this like I expect
did I actually expected it to be much
worse than it was like I said the vast
majority of people whether they're
Christians are not have been very
gracious I think the thing that I was
reminded of is just how big apart my ego
plays in anything that I talk about
right it's just like I'm obviously I was
trying to be as honest as I can when I
tell my story but I also kind of want to
be the hero of my own story
don't we all and in telling the story I
I'm also telling it in a way that
justifies my decisions and my
conclusions and there's really no other
way to live life in one sense but that
can be also done in a very unhealthy way
and I in we're gonna take a break here
in a second but I want to talk about how
that tendency to basically find personal
fault with someone who's deconstructing
is something that we relate to really
personally as well but a little story
but before that there's a bunch of
leashes we're gonna sell leashes
we've got leashes collars if you got a
pet go to mythical calm look at the
stuff that you can get for you but look
at the pattern on that link I don't
think we've ever had the privilege of
doing this but the pattern that is
behind us is the pattern that has made
its way onto this actual leash
yeah put ear biscuits on your dog or any
other type of animal that needs to be
leashed there's also a collar a big one
and a smaller one which Jade is
currently wearing she's at the groomer
she'd be in here right now
mythical calm rep yeah pets rep you boys
on your pets I I in terms of my
experience I would say I mean I shared
my story for me I shared you know when I
when I reach the conclusion it's like I
want to be hopeful I want to do the work
to remain engaged
in a faith journey and not just to be
not just sit on my laurels and go on
with my day-to-day life and there's so
much that I could get distracted by that
I would just never get back to it
I actually feel like sharing my story
was a big this is a big part of my
journey because it just helped me
process things for myself and I would
say kind of jump start okay or kind of
reinvigorate my own my own process
because for a number of years itted I
just kind of put it on a shelf you know
it's like I just I'm kind of stuck and I
don't you know but then the thing that I
started to realize as I prepped it and
then as I shared it started to come out
and even afterward as I've talked to
people about it I've really benefited
from understanding myself even more and
I can get into I'd like to get into some
of those details but at the same time at
a parallel path the fact that again
secondarily it was something that
resonated either your story or my story
or both of them resonated with so many
people that we didn't ask people I don't
know maybe we we I think I don't think
we asked for people to share their
stories I think we we acknowledge that
it was happening along the way but I
didn't anticipate that a lot of people
would just use it as an opportunity to
start to share their own stories to the
extent that they have and share how they
related to it to different aspects of
what we had to say and I was just you
know I would just I didn't know how to I
would just heart a lot of these things
because there were so many and I just I
wanted to reply and say something but
practically it just wasn't really
possible but I just wanted to say that
my experience was just being blown away
with
how our stories were helpful because
when you when you hear somebody share
something and there were people saying I
just I don't feel alone now that you
shared and again not just me you're
responding to you sometimes me sometimes
but it just means it means so much that
people are were moved were moved by it
too to not feel alone to be moved to
share their own stories and to just to
start that conversation with their
friends on the internet and off the
internet it was I was like wow I
actually think that it's helped people
and I really didn't know that that would
happen
i I don't maybe it seems obvious in this
internet culture of sharing that's like
yeah when you share and when you take a
risk it helps people but I never
associated that with what we were
considering doing and so I just remember
being in my bed one night and I was just
looking through all the stories and I
was just overwhelmed with gratitude that
that it did make a difference
and I again that's I didn't know that
was gonna happen
that was not I don't think I would have
said I'm doing this to help people I
think you know I was doing it as because
I thought I felt ready to do it and I
felt like it was part of my process so I
would I guess I was surprised maybe more
than you would have thought I would have
been well I wanted to I mean I want to
talk about how I interacted with all
that and like what how that while it was
helpful it also increased my anxiety I
want to get to that because I think
there's a whole conversation to have
there but I don't want to skip over our
the interactions that we've had with our
our old friend mm-hmm and yes if there's
a I mean we talked we talked about him a
little bit in one over one of our
stories maybe your story I can't
remember but there's yeah there's been a
number of people that we've reconnected
with but when we mentioned him we were
talking about how we were on the other
we you know we were still we were we
were on the front side of it and he was
kind of going through the process that
were yeah well we've been going into it
we've described to recap so this is a
very close friend of ours growing up who
was a fellow very strong Christian who
in the early 2000s basically started to
have somewhat of a deconstruction and we
reconnected with him well first of all
since our deconstruction we've connected
with him and we kind of we know where
we're each other or at but we told him
hey you know we're sharing our stories
publicly would love for you to listen or
whatever so that we've been kind of
talking with him since then he was able
to uncover some of our old
correspondence when link and I were
getting ready to go into the ministry to
work with Campus Crusade to do
evangelism training and we were running
some things by him as someone who was
you know in a different place but then
what he was doing actually we spent some
time with him he was going back and like
writing in his journal about the
interactions that he was having with us
and in reading so many of the responses
to this to our story especially the
responses from Ezra's oh you tell my
public responses yeah yeah so reading
public responses to our stories and
specifically responses from people who
are you know basically their only
response to what we said is this is just
very sad there's no like it's basically
just like I'm praying for you guys this
is very sad I hope you find the faith
those kinds of responses
he was a very very reminiscent of the
way that we interacted with him and it
just reminds me how much where we were
at in life and what we were doing was
informing our responses because we were
literally raising support to go on staff
full time and I had probably you were in
the very middle of it I was coming to
the end this giant sort of left turn in
your life where you've thrown you've
left your previous job and you're you're
putting it all on the line for Jesus
mm-hmm and then you go and you talk to a
friend who you really respect and we
probably we had the deepest sort of
intellectual conversations about our
faith even in high school with this guy
like this you know we talked about
things on as deep of a level as we could
at the time and in high school I
remember those conversations starting it
so it always kind of had this sort of
philosophical thing going with him and
then for him to have these really deep
questions that were kind of tearing at
the roots of our faith I remember me and
you talking to him and then talking to
each other and it was just like I think
the way you described it in a text to
him the other day was like we just had
there was zero openness to what you were
going through there was there was in it
there was a complete inability to turn
the questions that you were asking
yourself onto ourselves because there
was a way too much at stake at the time
yeah what are we gonna suddenly stop
races at port and tell everybody that
who just gave us all this money that oh
by the way guys I'm really questioning
the foundations of this whole thing it's
like I'm not gonna go there so I'm not
even gonna allow that thought to enter
my mind yeah so I my recollection was we
were you know we were as polite as we
could to be in trying to help help him
turn a corner to double back and that
was it you know it was like because
that's what we had that's what we were
supposed to do you know so it wasn't it
wasn't an actual conversation
and he you know he felt that and he knew
that he was also gracious because in his
journal entry basically said I
completely get where these guys are
coming from because it's where I came
from and that's why and so yeah I think
he said that he did to others what we
were doing to him and so all that to say
that any sort of dismissive comments
that we're getting about our story which
again is a very small minority it's more
than justified we deserve every bit of
it because we've done it we've been
there and it's that and I remember
thinking about him in thinking about I
was like where did you go wrong you know
like I think he hung out with the wrong
people
III you know I was trying to figure out
I was trying to get to the bottom of why
he someone who had a very real strong
informed faith was suddenly questioning
it and I was just like what did he where
did he screw up let me find that
let me find where he screwed up I never
could figure it out
so anyway I just I just wanted to
acknowledge that that we we've done that
and we've been there yeah so it's you
know I think there are people who are
coming to our defense because when they
see people say it makes me sad and I you
know and I you know I saw someone make
the point I don't think people realize
when they say that it makes them sad
when someone else shares their personal
story that that's manipulative but I get
it I understand why it it makes if you
have a certain worldview and it made me
sad before yeah or other people so but I
do think it's helpful I think it's
helpful and I listened I'm not saying
this but I think this could be this
could help those of you
who have said this is sad to understand
why it's not it's difficult to not take
that as an insult because if I were to
say you know it's sad that you that
you've based your life on something
that's not true that's that's offensive
that's an insult right to say that to
you if I'm not saying that's what I'm
not saying that but if I were to say
that that would be offensive would be
insulting it would be dismissive and so
I think the same thing is it's sad that
you guys are moving away from this thing
that I know to be true and it's sad that
your eternal destiny is in question I
listed I understand where you're coming
from and according to your worldview
this is pretty much the only response
that you could have right but to
communicate it in that way and not
understand why that's insulting and
dismissive and people are going to
perceive it in that way hopefully I've
shown a little bit of light on that I
think another thing that we didn't
anticipate was that people not that
people were going to come out of the
woodwork in order to text or email or
try to Facebook messages even though
we're not on Facebook anymore about
things is well it's it's not that that
surprises but that they would then reach
out to you know our wives or our
extended families and so that was
something that I don't know I don't know
if it would have changed how or if we
would have done it but it's not
something that we specifically
anticipated you know it's like I mean
Christy would get a bunch of messages
from people she hadn't heard from in a
while and I know they come from a place
of really caring but it's like then all
this now she's got a field questions
from people that are like it it was
basically like are you okay are you guys
okay and I was like Christine you know
the thing that I'm realizing is that it
was it was two years when I tell the
story of us in the minivan like in tears
not going in a church and trying to
figure
where we were and where we each were and
all those type of things and the anguish
from that particular story I told well
that was two years ago
you know it's like we're we've we're in
a different place than that we're not
sitting we don't have the minivan
anymore and even if we did we're not
sitting in it
weeping every Sunday you know we're in a
where we're in a much healthier healthy
is not the right word but like we're in
a good place and I don't you know and
people when you share this story and if
the last time they talked to you was
three four five six seven years ago it's
like what they don't they don't know
when that was so it's like it did this
just happen you know and really the
first thing Christie learned was the
first question she would ask you a
response to the people that she would
engage with was have you have you
actually listened to the podcast cuz a
lot of people they would hear from
someone and they would have concern but
they wouldn't have listened to it
themselves and so that's an important
point it's like I'm not gonna engage if
you don't really know all the details
already I can't I can't see her retell
you all yes in face on Facebook so even
from a purely practical standpoint it's
kind of like there's there's a handful
or maybe more than I am full of like oh
we got a I find myself in a conversation
with someone and it's like they're
bringing some assumptions to the table
that like we're in you were in trouble
yeah and that's not the case yeah I
didn't anticipate I mean if I should
have thought about it but I was thinking
about a lot of things leading up to us
talking and I did not anticipate given
the nature of a small town and a
community of people who at least in the
circles that my family runs in back home
it's like you know we're talking about a
Christian a Christian circle of people
yeah very well-connected group of people
both my family and Jesse's family
so it's like the amount of people who
have kind of come up to them saying
things making assumptions again having
not listened to the podcast in many
cases yeah I feel like I could have
prepared them better I feel bad about
that I think that's been that's been a
source of some anxiety for me as well as
I've thought about this because you know
they knew that we were going to talk
about it to some degree some more than
they're back there on kind of the
frontlines it's like we've been dealing
with a lot of the on lines nobody nobody
comes about he was la3 yet yeah you know
what else you're not he had the
groceries at a restaurant in a grocery
store and somebody's gonna come up to
you know yeah so I guess we could have
done we could have done better
yeah on that front but I wanted to I
wanted to talk about what you were
saying with the number of the way that I
interacted with the number of like
stories that people were telling and a
number of people who related now my
initial reaction was one of this is
awesome this is super encouraging like
you said it was a very there's a few
times where I was just reading people's
stories it was very very emotionally
he's a very emotional thing it's like
people have been through some [ __ ] man
yeah
in contrast to to our stories like I
said like I said it was very difficult
to kind of move out of that world but
that world we benefited personally and
from that world in a lot of ways that
other people have a lot more trauma
depending on their their background and
some of those stories are just
heart-wrenching but the way that again
so there's there's sort of my heart
reaction to it which is this is great
and then there's my head reaction to it
which is like what are we gonna do with
this you know I'm always thinking about
what the next thing is that we're gonna
do and yeah I thought about that when
when you got all these people sharing
this story and their feels like there's
this momentum and there
feels like there is this you know we've
all kind of left something that was very
organized and was a very particular
movement into this thing that it's just
pretty nebulous what is this life after
Christian faith yeah are you talking
about thoughts that enter your mind like
well should we organize something no no
no no no no I want to be clear I want to
be clear I'm I'm too I'm too old and
just wise enough to know that that would
be a horrible idea I'm not talking about
a rental encoder complexion of this
podcast to have some programmatic
addressing of some of these things I
would say in a more general sense it's
just asking the question of is there a
project associated with this right hmm
that's one question that enters my mind
is like is there a project I don't know
what that is but you got all these
people they've got their stories there's
this momentum we've tapped into
something and so I feel this pressure to
sort of figure that out at the same time
I'm feeling this pressure to like you
said this has sort of been a kick in the
pants to like sort of re-engage
spiritually for me that's been true but
it's also kind of the way that it's
registered with me is I threw out this
deconstruction story and talked about
what I what I don't believe anymore I
talked a little bit about what I do
believe now but what I do believe now is
held with a much lower level of
conviction and passion mm-hmm because
it's more of a position of openness and
curiosity but that I don't want to be in
that position perpetually and never
embrace anything right but there was
this sort of like people like you just
again you just threw this rock into the
hornet's nest and now you got these
Hornets flying around and some of them
are coming up to you and asking well
what now you know and I'm not trying to
put on the mantle of some spiritual
leader that's the last thing that I want
to do because that's not a it's very
much the last thing that I ever want to
do but there is this part of me that's
like well you should find some answers
you know you should find some answers
and then you should relay those answers
and again I just feel like that is
rooted in my ego I don't think that
that's rooted in anything good I don't
think that there's I think it's very
much about a personal personal interest
and personal self justification I don't
think that there's any I should be
leaning into that that doesn't mean that
I shouldn't be personally you know
seeking and being open and being open to
whatever is next for me which I think
that I am but doing that because I want
to then present myself to a group of
people who are listening is a bright and
the interesting thing trapped ironically
that's what ministry is for so many
people that's what any position of
leadership is but I've known I've got a
lot of friends who are pastors and I've
had a lot of friends who are pastors and
some of them in their most honest
moments have relayed to me
that there is this sort of
self-fulfilling prophecy I don't know
that's probably not the right
terminology but there is this idea that
now I am the one that you are coming to
for answers and so I must create the
answers I must have the answers I must
live the life I must have the appearance
of having it figured out because that is
what you expect of me and I think that a
lot of pastors are just kind of stuck in
this it's tough hamster wheel of
appearances and kind of and the church
in a lot of ways has set it up that you
can't
you can't screw up you can't you can't
be a human you you can't have
imperfections especially if you're in
leadership especially if you're the
pastor right yeah I feel I feel for them
and but I'll I'll draw an analogous
scenario for us I was on a Valentine's
date with Kristy and first of all
there's a story that I'm not gonna tell
now maybe I'll tell it next week when
it's like when we have more space for
this so don't let me forget it's this
funny thing that happen but that's kind
of my point I was in a dinner and
another another weird thing happened
that I'm not referring to and I made a
joke to Kristy at dinner and I was like
oh you know I'm gonna talk about - so
near biscuits and it was like and she
you know she got she was like uh-uh
are you serious it's like and it wasn't
that she didn't want me to share a funny
story it's just that we're on a date
this is about me and her and if I'm
sitting there the moment something
happens I'm like oh yeah I got a air
biscuit story then that Rob's the the
intimacy of the moment you know it's
like well we just had a funny moment you
know we didn't we experienced a funny
moment that you can then have on an
audience later you know it's like and I
was like actually I was just joking
because I that was my joke Kristy well
that was my defense it's just a joke but
I'm talking about it on your business
right now
no I'm talking about talking about
talking about it but I'm not talking
about it okay but maybe next week I'll
share another story but not this one
because I'm it's off limits now because
that's a sacred precious just between
you and Christie but my point I hear
your point when it comes to like am I
gonna pursue am I gonna like let's just
say it's fine an answer to to a specific
spiritual philosophical question for
yourself are you going to find that
question so you just so you can turn
around and prove that you have an answer
on your biscuits like that's dangerous
a trap you know it's a trap for certain
personalities my personality listen it's
a trap for me and it's it's one of the
ways that I interacted with
responsibilities in the church right
it's like yeah of course I'm gonna lead
a Bible study right and of course every
once in a while if they asked me I'll
preach give a talk on something and I
think there's a Iran eclis the way and
of course our experiences with the
evangelical church but the way the
evangelical church is structured at this
point is typically men who are type-a
personalities who would otherwise make
great CEOs make really good pastors in
the system that is currently set up and
they're charismatic leaders not
charismatic in the theological sense but
just winning personalities they're smart
they're insightful they're not a relate
they not tell a good story and every
quickly find hundreds if not thousands
of people who want in and I think it
just creates a really unhealthy for I
know for me personally if we had a
stayed in ministry I'm sure that that's
we would have taken some sort of path in
leadership and I think I operated in a
really unhealthy place for a really long
time I know I did I described it you
know as it like a as a worship leader
yeah what but the interesting thing is
that to get back to the what we're gonna
do with this momentum or whatever it is
and this is kind of what I was talking
about in therapy last night is finding a
way to just lean into the personal
nature of the process but it not being
about a movement it not being about
being right being justified being the
Bible answer man yeah you know what I'm
saying
and having an answer and having a reason
for everything because very quickly
almost immediately that just becomes
about me
it just becomes about me wanting to
justify myself and to get your approval
you know in my the whole process that
I've been going through and therapy is
leaning it's leaning away from that and
being like it's not no no no it's not
about people's approval is it's not
about what people think about you it's
about figuring out what is actually
happening in your heart and so I think
it's so my desire for when we talk about
these things on the podcast is just it -
I'm not saying we shouldn't answer a
question or - at some point even now I
don't know probably not now we're almost
out of time but I want the tone of that
and the purpose of that to be hey I'm
not an expert just a couple of guys
trying to figure out life trying to move
closer to the truth doing our best yeah
for me I like I said the the process of
share my story really helped me almost
internalize some conclusions about like
realizing things about who I was and
about how I interact like the way that I
interacted with my faith and my belief
system and what that what that meant
about me as a person then what it means
for me now and well there there's one
tweet from Holly that I wanted to read
she said I too was raised evangelical
and a man Enneagram one like me I
struggled my whole life trying to be a
quote better Christian and it wasn't
until after college that I realized I
was exhausted from living with this
internal struggle and that is the this
process of putting this out there has
really helped me begin
to understand to a new level my own
internal struggle and that there is
absolutely a level of exhaustion that I
did not know that was there
associated with my perfectionism my
underlying anxiety and again it's I know
that there's a lot of anxiety there and
I and it's not all from my experience
within the church it's from a lot of
things and so it really provided the
occasion for me to say you know what I
am going to go to therapy i I'm not just
gonna talk about it you know we've
talked about it a lot
Christy and I have talked about it a lot
some of our closest friends we've talked
about it for years and it almost felt
like I was practically going to therapy
but that's also that's so wrong that's
so linked yeah you you have this and I
can't call it I just but you have this
tendency that I've noticed throughout
our lives together that like sometimes
just like when somebody close to you
kind of starts doing something or is
interested in something you're just like
yeah yeah I'm by proxy interest today
I'm I'm by proxy so I think you've been
experiencing the benefits of therapy
because the people you're closest with
we keep going you pick up on all right
and it's not like we don't read and
discuss a lot of the same books but last
night ironically the same time you were
at therapy I was at my first therapy
appointment and I don't think without
going through this process I would I
would have pulled the trigger on setting
up that appointment you know the first
thing I'm gonna see here and give you a
play-by-play but you know it's just one
hours not a lot when you're trying to
get it when you're when you have as much
as I have that you're trying to get out
so it's but you know I'm
I'm very excited to have taken that step
and to me it's a tangible step for me
personally as a result of Desai you know
to follow through on the commitment that
I made to myself and just share it at
the end of my story that was I do want
to work at understanding and loving
myself more and explaining my capacity
to love others more and also to pursue
faith to me those things are connected
if I can't I don't I don't think if I if
I can't start to love myself more yeah I
don't know if I can receive any love
from God if if if that love is to be
there to be received you know so I it's
again I'm just getting started but I'm
very I'm excited
I know it's I know there's a lot of pain
associated with therapy and that I also
know that there that I have a lot of
that there's this that there's this fear
that is there's somewhere in me that
then on the underside of that there's
things that I've been afraid to explore
but my my hope and my excitement to to
to grow in to work at it is overrides
the the fear that I think that maybe has
always been there and I think this
process has helped me realize so and
again to hear like Holly's tweet that
like she related to that it was just
hearing hearing that somebody related
then kind of doubled back on itself and
helped me understand myself even better
hearing it in somebody else's words it's
like well this is how I feel and this is
the words that I would put it in of
being exhausted
it's like wow yeah that that is me so
it's it's it's already come back and I
just feel I'm grateful that we've done
it just for me personally and I you know
I cannot own how other people process it
for them that's that's on them well you
know if we are gonna answer a question I
think you know you're kind of getting
very close to it already
a question that I saw a number of times
was why why tell this story mm-hmm
it may be even more specifically there
were people who were like why tell this
story what if you're wrong what if
you're wrong and you're leading an
untold number of people depending on the
popularity of this podcast in down the
wrong path do you really want that you
really want that on your shoulders you
want to be responsible for that I think
that most of those comments are coming
from people who haven't been listening
to the podcast and I don't just mean the
episodes I mean the podcast as a whole
yeah because I think that anyone who's
been on board for any length of time has
sort of seen this coming because we have
gotten increasingly personal and in
solisten some people are like I would
never do that I would never talk about
what is happening to me in therapy and
have thousands of people listen to it
I listen I get that I respect that
and I don't exactly know why this is the
way that we've chosen to do what we're
doing and in some ways this podcast has
become therapy it has become very
therapeutic right because we talked
about I talked to my therapist in the
way that I talked to you guys what
on here right it's just very much like
you kind of just start talking and see
what happens and I don't know if there's
just this increased desire for
vulnerability and being able to just
communicate that with a wider audience I
don't know what the motivations are and
I don't know exactly how we got here I
just know that like you said the idea of
continuing to kind of pull back the
curtain and be like this is this is just
two guys trying to live life and figure
it out and if you want to be in the on
the conversation listen in on the
conversation of two guys who've known
each other forever who are best friends
who work together husbands and fathers
and now people who've deconstructed from
their former Christian faith you want to
be along for the ride then let's do it
let's do it together but it because it
had gotten that the tone had gotten so
vulnerable and there was so much about
disclosure self disclosure and because
it was so related to our careers like we
can't honestly talk about why we do what
we do as a as an actual career without
talking about how we got here and
telling the full story and we honestly
can't tell the full story without
putting our perspective on those years
into perspective
which then requires us to tell our story
personally yeah yeah it all kind of fit
together but I think another answer is
that we are discovering that when you
are vulnerable it opens you up to more
love and more empathy for again for
yourself and for your best friend and
for other people what I just described
it like I shared it from I share my
story for me other people it helped
other people and
in that response helped me you know it's
just the the way people look at it like
a show and yes we we have to set
boundaries for ourselves and we have to
be like the thing we talked about a few
minutes ago about like whether it's on
the date or like our version of being
the preacher but so yeah we have to be
we have to be protected we have to set
boundaries and we have to we're gonna be
learnt we're going to learn that as we
go but we're able to and I'm grateful
that we're able to have an honest
conversation in front of a microphone
that we would have if it wasn't here
we've talked about how we have them a
lot more because they're here then if
the microphone is not here but then we
also it it's just I what I'm saying is
we're conducting a an honest friendship
it just happens to be recorded and I'm
just what people do with it is is their
business but I we also experience a
greater capacity for connection with and
love with an audience because it's not
just some people sitting in chairs
listening it's it's individual people
who were then contributing to a
conversation it's it's not like we're
going on television it's a dis a
different thing you know and the nature
of the conversation has been really
refreshing can i and I just want to I
want to read this one thing on it on the
the discord channel of the mythical
society which is if you don't know
that's our fan club and yes you got to
pay for it I'm not promoting it but I'm
just saying it like I'm I was just so
encouraged by this one exchange and I'm
not gonna read the whole thing but there
was the sixteen-year-old guy who was he
just he was processing
our ear biscuits and he was and he just
shared that he's he's had a devout set
set of beliefs the specifics of which
aren't pertinent and that you know he
was impacted by our conversation and it
was parts of it it kind of shook him up
and he was just sharing that not with us
but just in the discord and then a
response from one particular mythical
beast I just want to read part of it
why adult think I remember being there
as a teenager so I definitely know what
you're going through my best advice is
just to trust yourself and to remember
that there's nothing wrong with
questioning and researching on your own
and coming to your own conclusions
remember that no matter what your
religion teaches there is nothing wrong
with questioning or having doubts and
that whatever conclusions you come to or
choices that you make make sure that
you're making them for yourself
and no one else you may have people try
to guilt you into making a certain
decision or believe in a certain way
because they want you to believe the way
they do I know I definitely did but
ultimately no one but you can decide
what you believe and then the response
was yeah that's that's what I need to
hold on to and then there was some more
there and it says if you need support I
know there are a ton of people in this
server who would be happy to talk or
listen and if there's anything in
particular you're struggling with we
might be able to provide resources again
I really appreciate it was the response
and III think there there are a couple
of things there you know I it just seems
like that's the message that I talk to
my kids about you know it's and it is
such I mean it is such a big deal to say
okay you need to you
have to make these decisions for
yourself no one can make these decisions
for you they can but you really need to
make these decisions for yourself no
matter what it is you're going to be
loved and supported by this community
which is my second point that I've just
blown away that that one example is
repeated again and again that there's so
many people in our community and then it
gives me hope for Humanity at large that
there's that level of love and support
for people that it you know even if
you're not talking about the specifics
of what do I agree with you on this or
are we on the same page or are you right
or are you wrong but it's love and
support and encouragement to to to deal
with those things in the most healthy
way possible these issues that are so
important and I was just grateful for
that and that's why we don't we don't
want the conversation to devolve into an
argument right yeah about the finer
points of theology and and again it's
not that I don't think I just want to be
really clear it's not that we don't
think that you having your own answers
as close to the truth as possible isn't
is not important as I hope I
demonstrated in my story it's like
because those answers are important is
why I don't believe like I used to
believe right it isn't that those
theological points and examining and
those things are not important they're
very important but the moment that they
become a source of contention between
people and the moment that you take love
out of your interaction you're missing
the point
regardless of what side of the issue
your honor I think that just the idea
because what you're basically what
you're talking about is that the most
simple eh
in Corning but the most important thing
is love right it's like what is my ethic
or what it what are my ethics at this
point it's love and I and I actually
think that asking that question in any
given situation what is the most loving
response what is the most loving way
forward in this situation is a pretty
good guide and incidentally that's very
consistent with what Jesus taught you
know faith hope and love the greatest of
these is love
mm-hmm I don't think that I don't I
think that regardless of where you're at
and where you come down on these
particular issues and what you think
about the nature of life and the nature
of eternity you're not going to go wrong
if you kind of fall back on that what
would what is the most loving thing that
I could do in this situation and like
link said I think that it's been super
encouraging that the vast majority of
the conversation has been loving and
respectful we have an incredible
community we value that a lot and that's
and that's the conversation that loving
conversation is what we want to continue
to engender and it's not about two guys
who are listening we may have
engineering degrees but we're just in
we're YouTube comedians that's what we
are we're not authorities on any of
these issues if you're coming to either
one of us to figure out what you think
about your faith there are much better
sources and so that was that was not the
intention at all and telling our stories
was you to be convinced that we were
right it's just very much hey this is
what our process was this is what our
story was you should be doing your own
investigation but all we all we just
want to we just want to be about love
it's that simple and on that note can I
recommend a children's book
sure I was reading this book to Lando he
pulled it off his shelf and this is my
wreck in effect this week it's called
the three questions written and
illustrated by John gon J mu mu th the
three questions is based on a story by
Leo Tolstoy a short story that I had
never read and so as I was reading this
children's book to Lando I was just
moved and it's it's very pertinent to
the conversations that we've been having
and it was just like it felt like a fate
moment I'll be honest that I was I mean
like Lando started looking at me weird
because I was like tearing up and I was
like this book this is amazing there's
there's something there's some wisdom in
this and I didn't realize that it was
and it was based on a Leo Tolstoy a
short story until we were done reading
it but like I could sense that there was
some depth to this thing so you know
what I'm not gonna tell you about it but
I recommend if you you know
Lando's 9 he was very much into it but
you don't have to have kids to read it
I actually recommend this children's
book adaptation instead of just
listening to or inaudible or or reading
the Leo Tolstoy short story of the same
name though I do recommend that story as
well but the way that it's turned is
more modernized and it's a little bit
more existential is um it's it's very
powerful so that's my that's my
recommendation where you read it to me a
kid's when you come over to my house to
read it to me and tuck me in tonight
gladly yeah good yeah hashtag ear
biscuits let let's continue the
conversation and I'm not it listen we
will we were gonna answer some questions
at some at some point so I don't want to
I don't want everybody think we've just
completely thrown all your questions
aside we've still got a bunch of them
we'll get back we'll get back to them
we're just trying to send zero in on the
tone of how we're gonna approach those
thanks for listening to watch more ear
this gets click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best
[Music]